ambiance décontractée et estival mardi
en fin d'après midi à versailles ou pour
le soutenir dans sa campagne des
législatives le député sortant modem de
la 2e circonscription des yvelines jean
noël barrot avait invité le ministre de
l'économie et des finances bruno le
maire le ministre plutôt bien accueillis
notamment par le patron du lieu qui au
nom des restaurateurs lui dit vous nous
avez sauvé et qui ajoute
bruno le maire s'est prêté au jeu des
questions réponses sur la retraite sur
le pouvoir d'achat notamment et sur un
plan plus politique il a surtout insisté
sur l'enjeu de ces élections c'est bien
à quelques jours maintenant du premier
tour de montrer à quel point il ya un
enjeu fondamental pour cette élection
législative s'est donné une majorité
claire opposant la république pour qu'il
puisse mettre en oeuvre son programme de
revalorisation du travail son programme
de plein emploi son programme de soutien
aux entrepreneurs son programme de
construction européenne tout ça a besoin
du soutien des électeurs le ministre de
l'économie et des finances double ipa
qu'il vient de la droite d'où peut-être
ce clin d'oeil à ce qui brille et
inscrit toujours l air pourrait
rejoindre un jour les maquereaux nist et
notamment au président du conseil
départemental des yvelines pierre bédier
ce qui est très bien pierre bédier je
n'ai aucun doute que pierre bédier aura
à coeur de soutenir certains projets de
la majorité parce qu'ils s'y reconnaîtra
parfaitement la valorisation du travail
de soutien aux entrepreneurs la défense
d'une nation unie autour de règles de
valeurs communes la volonté de peser sur
le destin européen tous à pierre baignée
s'y retrouvera parfaitement je le sais
un dernier mot quand même pour celui
qu'il est venu soutenir jean noël barrot
ah oui pourquoi voter pour lui il est
super compétent est super sympa
ça fait deux bonnes raisons de voter
pour lui
pression est gâté
m sanglots